all right so we are currently at the
Cirque du Soleil training space they're
praying for their new show called run
which is like an action fight thriller
and live it's crazy so I don't know much
about it yet we're gonna learn about it
today we're gonna train yeah
hopefully we don't die or break any
bones but I am ready to beat up Eric I'm
so excited what wait what I'm just super
excited because I I was always a fan of
Cirque du Soleil when I was a little kid
my parents took me the show and I
remember always like begging to be in
the show afterwards like I wish they'd
call me up on stage or something cuz I
could do handstands and different tricks
you cuz I breakdance so now like my
dreams are coming true I get a train
hopefully I get hired by the end of this
and why I left BuzzFeed I don't know my
anxiety is like getting through me to do
this in front of people but I think I
could I think I could do you get nervous
in front of people like performing and
stuff no I just get nervous 24/7 it's
just a confident saying I got you thank
you guys
I'm pretty good he's trying to psych me
out right now and I don't like it what
I'm really hoping to get out of this is
like I never whenever I get auditions or
anything I never get like the badass
character I really want to change that
and like become someone who can fight
and like stand my ground because I'm not
that I got punched at a bar one time and
just set out and walked away if anyone
tries to fight me in a bar I'll be like
you know I trained with Cirque run okay
I could like make you fake flip right
now real hard so we're gonna meet to the
performers right now get it to makeup
and then we're gonna start from there I
might have to say I'm Stefano right hi
I'm Audrey you guys do your own makeup
before each show so you're like doing
tattoos on yourself and you're like
painting everything on basically yeah
it's more complicated than like James
Charles right there so we're gonna be
training with you two later
and fighting you is
i'm super-nervous i want you guys to go
as easy on this as possible
hi my fright is that I'm just gonna
break a bone on camera so so right now
we should just get our makeup done yeah
we're gonna pause and just follow the
little booklet right the 25 page
[Music]
they're hard like putting makeup on
yourself because in the mirror
everything's backwards I'm so mad at how
typical this is so is this the first
show you've designed like stuff for sexy
so I actually know I've been working
with SIF since 25 years so I create 25
shows during that time it looks so real
and so easy out on because prosthetics
usually take like a long face a good six
hours to put on prosthetics yeah that's
like a 30-second thing yeah it moves
with my mouth it does all that stuff you
did that and now there are tattoos that
are part of the show and we're gonna put
other tattoos
you have the mask I do thank you
[Music]
Oh bro please an eagle is that an eagle
on my neck
what is that I thought would be
intimidating to fight a dude who's got
spikes in his nose and ears like I'm not
intimidated at all
no no just stab you with my nose right
now do you feel tougher I'm like a
lopsided unicorn you know what I mean
they made me get a tattoo and a bunch of
piercings all right so we finished our
makeup and now we're gonna go through a
little warm-up before we start the
training yeah we don't pull any muscles
and don't get injured you other breath
you have a good good breathing through
my nose my friend knockout talking to
town on the black man cash in cash out
hands up and down you can I hit em with
that new Japan summer writing yeah you
come back with a Marshall are back with
a Basel spark on Saturday my dog come
meet me in the bottle and we finna go
all right guys we just finished the
warm-up for the circuit raining it's not
a tear this is real sweat I'm still
finish this kid over here he thinks he's
better than me I don't know why I do so
many fitness challenges for BuzzFeed so
I I have like a pretty good idea like
what a good workout is it's not what
Eric is doing right now
but these are tough this is like no joke
this is a serious these guys do this for
hours on end and then they do
performances on top of that but yeah I'm
already sweaty and we just got through
the warm-up so I expect the training to
be a lot more difficult and I will
probably be drenched in sweat by the end
of it so we're gonna split up and
actually train with usual former so I'm
gonna train with one
right now we're in my head I need this
right now cuz I'm the best at this the
first business and the last the first
I'll be the first one okay don't look at
me I like have too much nerves I think
Spencer's just really nervous he's in
his head because I think he just used to
like working out and being like super
athletic but like choreography or or
things that involve
like like it's almost like a dance or a
performance I think he gets more
stressed about it but hopefully overcome
Zach it's really good
[Music]
so you can never leave the limit oh my
god I'm making so many sound effects I
literally just said
[Music]
excellent
nice all right so let's uh I'll start
with you there's a rule that we had what
sells action is you have an idea we're
at the reaction there you go
like you got you got a hit in the
stomach and you wouldn't like this
though a lot of people do the same
mistake right it's the body you're gonna
take a chef to the body and you go I
contact very important will you pardon
number three is distancing you know
distance very important make sure you're
not too close you know when you do a
headbutt you know don't be good
just this move before but now's better
[Music]
next you could even as you stumble fat
you should leave it for I'm trying to do
a pleasure and boom I get it
oh you don't stand still waiting to get
it like a punching bag so you did this
more acting into it
here we go that was much better
nice go alright guys we just tested out
our stunts we're gonna go to the other
room with all the other actors and we're
gonna perform in front of them and
hopefully we don't mess up too badly
it's incredible to work with a
professional stunt coordinator it's
super intimidating as well knowing that
this guy has worked on movies like
Deadpool and 300 and all of that with
very famous actors so they come in from
like the athlete point of view where I'm
like physically fit and I can do moves
it just takes a lot to actually like
memorize it and do it in my brain and
like perfectly
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
he's dead he's dead he's dead I'm proud
of overcame Europe
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for this
experience who's honestly incredible
I've always dreamed of being a part of
Cirque du Soleil and this is like making
my dreams come true to get the train and
Spencer and I got to come out to Vegas
and learn some fight choreography and
now I can send it to my agents and get I
get another acting job so I thought were
you really appreciated thank you guys so
much
[Applause]
[Music]
what is written in the plexi case
one-in-a-million ability is ahead to say
wanna be a winner then
what the beep